and what's happened to austin he said
i'm sinking he's dead
look at him
a year later the team discovers um
yes is a lovely game uh
it is a debut game it's it's
very um point-and-click adventure
uh in a lot of those and yeah really
sweet setting
it's a lovely little game i'm a big fan
are you a point-and-click adventure
person yeah i'm i'm also
camp grim fandango is fantastic i'm a
huge fan of grooming yes
oh gee like the the og or the reason i
was gonna well i thought you were going
to go with a different one i was getting
ready to
do you another grandfather
come on
you're fine that's going to be a call of
duty um
modern warfare 2.
there is an unused score from pirates of
the caribbean there's a lot of stuff
just apropos what i was just playing
i think there's a lot of people that go
oh man modern warfare was great
and then they remember that it was
actually that was in modern warfare 2
they go
no i'm pretty sure there's a modern
warfare's like no one doesn't model well
one wolf is an interesting one because
that game
like just blew that franchise up and i
think also had a pretty significant
impact
on multiplayer gaming in general how
about the fact that that's when we
started getting like
do you want to see violent images that's
where that game started that's that that
started with that
yeah there are no russians no because of
no russian
they had to add in do you want i
remember that images
yeah is that common though i feel like
i feel like i don't see that very often
like like the last of us didn't probably
i think you
probably do you're probably just so used
to it that it doesn't register because i
mean like ubisoft always has the like
all religions faiths
splash screen now for every game and i
think every call of duty might have
violent images screen wait every ubisoft
game does it or just
just assassin's creed i believe every
ubisoft game does it but i could be
wrong
i'm trying to think of like spiders i
think watchdogs
did legions did have that i do think so
but that's not that's different that's
different from an opt opt-out
or opt-in sure yeah thing the way modern
warfare
yeah modern warfare 2. speak for
yourself
austin some of us like to opt out as
soon as we find out that our games are
made by diverse teams
that's what that screen's there for i'm
like yeah
out of here dropping the controller i
don't want to play it
i'm glad i'm several religions
it's it's not exactly not to be the only
person
what made by a muslim this guy by the
way is from new jersey
i live in hoboken in the middle
smackdown in the middle of the city
i was going to say i'm glad to not be
the only one with the uh
wonderfully unflattering out of context
uh sentences and and you've you've
you've done me very well in the last
five seconds i would like to say that i
really liked your comment on that austin
that somebody said
this sounds really bad out of context
and then you replied and said as do most
things out of context is like that is
very true anything sounds bad out of
context
definitely i i don't think it
necessarily sounds bad i think it's it's
to me it's instantly more compelling or
at least provocative
if it's taken out of context well yeah
the the video on youtube
on the that on twitter of me going
apparently all women look the same
just with zero framing zero
people just went here we go
i don't even really find that bad it's
like
as resident woman spokesperson it's like
yeah if you could tell us what the
consensus is
you can speak to this i was fine with it
so um the women have spoken it's fine uh
it is allowed you guys are fine um also
hello everyone i'm gonna
catch you all off guard and intro the
podcast right now what
i remember the show uh welcome to play
watch listen i'm a lot of peace video
game writer that's mike bithell video
game director that's troy baker video
game actor and that's austin wintery
video game composer
and i wanted to introduce why is mike
bithell sorry why is mike bethel like
our man on the street correspondent
right now he's got his
headphone cord he's a secret service
pain in the last cup wait i've been
wearing this for a couple of episodes
now because it's just easier
and less annoying than all the airpod
shenanigans i have to deal with every
week
so do you not like it do you not like
security guys because i'm wearing the
suit as well it makes me look like i'm
outside that's a reference
i'm not referencing that but i did want
to related to that say
this is going to be a short episode
because we recorded something
because we're all wearing suits yes we
can only rent them for 30 minutes at a
time yes
yeah the guy comes over in a few hours
together our tuxedo place
also is a brothel
here you want to see some real class you
know what though i'm actually impressed
let's do this here's here's my class i'm
really impressed that we all had these
i bought mike i think you're the same as
me yesterday
i bought well no you're great it's less
is your dress a formal dress would it be
akin to like a tuxedo
uh well let me just
a lot of odds that we're in the magic oh
fair play yeah
these are casual um no it's it's like a
jumpsuit kind of that i'm wearing
uh sweatpants on them all right
i love we just instantly are like
formal it is formal it is quite formal
you just can't see that it is quite
formal
i just don't most guys don't own a
tuxedo like i think that was a very
anachronistic thing like in the 50s
whether you had your gin martinis
then men is like of course i've got my
gin martini i've got my camo cigarettes
and my tuxedo
am i supposed to need to wear them often
enough and i work
you hit a saturation point that's the
thing isn't it i was like it was when i
was renting it for like the
second or third time in a year and i
realized like there was
probably more costly people in the games
industry like
go to events sort of frequently like
there's only one that you have
you have a point where just every other
one is like please try to look
presentable
and only badly just don't wear jeans
anything
don't wear jeans and a t-shirt for your
last game you get
one one day a year you don't have to
wear a hoodie please
just play every time jeff keeley is like
please look good and bafta is always
just like oh no no no we won't let you
inside
yeah because in america this is what
servers wear
you know it's like this is not like
formal no
i one time went to a i went to an event
like a
uh and it was an ascap uh event
and so it was you know a lot of people
wearing suits and stuff
and i had this white sport coat like
from the opening of temple of doom
and i was so excited to finally have a
chance to because the only other time i
wore it was
while conducting the leisure suit larry
recordings
yeah exactly so i show up i show up and
i'm like i'm i'm going full
white suit and i show up and within 15
seconds people are coming up to me going
i'm gonna get another can i yeah can i
get a wine over at my table
and i was and i'm looking at it all the
caterers are indifferentiable from me
and i was like i literally can't
ever use it you looked capable you
looked like a man who could be trusted
to deliver the drinks to 80 percent of
people in the games
the ironic thing is i could carry a tray
i have genuine admiration for waiters
like especially when they
you never carry like this stack you
don't carry a tray like this i
just assume you carry them like this
it's
uh yes impossible for me impossible
surely surely austin you've done uh you
you did like a bar job or
uh i never had never had
my favorite bad job was uh delivering
jumping inflatable jumping castles to
kids parties
where you have to carry these things and
they weigh ten thousand pounds
and uh just blow them up before you
leave
that job made me never want to go near
any of those ever again because you
realize they're almost impossible to
clean
and so you're like a bunch of kids you
know like
vomiting on the inside of this thing and
then yeah it's terrible no one should
ever go in those
that or mcdonald's which is worse uh
well i worked at mcdonald's
and i know that's why i'm asking you
that'd be nice um no my wife's job was
still definitely working at a call
center
that that's an awful job unanimously um
was my first full-time job when i was
volunteer games writing when i started
out
it's atrocious um call call in or call
out text
you know what i mean so they would call
us we talked about this it was bad but
the
the bigger issue that i had with it was
also that it was an international
company and we would get
people from other countries who would
call and would be like hey i think it's
disgusting that you have a woman in the
workplace talking about tech can i
please speak to your manager
like i got called filthy because i was
answering the phone they were like
disgusting yep filthy catch excuse me is
there a man there i could tell yeah but
it wasn't like that
it was it was like they wanted me to die
for having a job kind of
like context like this in the 50s like
what was this
what what uh darling go right now don't
get your boss where they were from
that was the attitude but it was uh it
was it was like probably one of those
polls a week where i would just like by
the end i was just like
okay well you're disturbed by the fact
that i'm a woman working in tech and i
will forward this call on to my manager
it was and i liked her
i'm gonna go be a woman in games yeah
in tech support of what kind of like
what are people calling what
tech was this support uh it was dns
so uh specifically websites so domain
name service um so it's helping them run
their websites
and also um usually the email addresses
that were tied
to their servers wouldn't work that's
such
innocuous that's such an innocuous tech
support to come like
loaded for bear and the on this misogyny
you know you're not saying that there's
any kind of logic to misogyny
like i mean well no you're already if
you're in that mindset you're already an
idiot
well of course of course deny that for
bear mean
that you're just you're even if a bear
shows up you're ready you're like
either that or you're you're drunk
enough to have sex it's not like a
common phrase in america
i've never heard loaded for bear isn't
that like an alaska
isn't that like an alaska thing of you
know having uh like your magnum pistol
that's
like you're ready for that's like
literally you can deal with like a
kodiak
i thought that was actually the country
that was my approach i feel like
this episode is already a mess but i'm
gonna make it more messy
by telling you a story about my friend
who recently made news headlines
because she was in alaska she went to
use her outhouse
uh and got bitten on the ass by a bear
wait wait it was inside of the toilet it
was her
was it like a baby i guess kind of how
did your bear fit in the toilet
how did it get in there it just crawled
in the back in the behind like so it's
like you know one of those like
it was inside of the like toilet tank
and she's
asking for help on the ass gets up and
walks away
calls like they hear her screaming so
other people come in and they look in
and they just see a bear
just staring up at them inside of a
toilet poor buddy
you said australia by the way that was a
big poo
well in australia it would have been
like a poison bear so that's the
difference
and it's on fire but eight legs yeah
exactly
oh my god the worst story that i've ever
heard about australia
is there was uh they found a woman
they found this woman who um
had drowned um or had asphyxiated run
out of oxygen they had no idea what
happened to her
and they found out that there she found
this cute little
fish little starfish or whatever she was
like oh that's adorable
and so she put it in her like i'm gonna
keep that
because i found it in the wild in the
ocean and she put it in her suit
and it had this poison barb that went
pink and it injects
a poison that paralyzes you oh
[ __ ] doesn't make you unconscious
just makes you paralyzed so her lungs
paralyzed that's just some
final destination level right i was like
what did you do and so she's just
oh here i am just going to die and i was
like
i'm never going in the water nightmare
yeah i remember standing on the beach
[ __ ] from
that's probably poisonous that wants to
murder me i remember reading that
go ahead go ahead go ahead please go
ahead
what i'm gonna say is very sad so well i
i remember
hearing about as a toilet as a scuba
diver
i remember hearing that in australia you
know they have the the bit like the
manowar
uh nets that they'll put out outside of
beaches
because the super poisonous jellyfish
and man of war will come
drifting in but that there are some
species that are so small that no net
can can stop them and those are the like
far and away the most poisonous ones
and so it's just it's the same thing as
your as your fish story where
it's like this basically micro plastic
sized uh grain of sand jellyfish will
like
brush up against your leg and just kill
you it's like
everything about this this island is
telling us
go away again it's very sad and it sucks
and i don't talk about it often but um
my labrador when she was four years old
got bitten by a tick and died within 24
hours
24 hours she was on all of the right
medication all the anti-tick prevention
medication
it just paralyzed her and then she died
and it was like
yeah my mom was visiting me in san
francisco at the time and uh
we were actually at yosemite when it
happened my aunt was also wait that was
here
my aunt waited for us to drive back to
san francisco before telling us and it
was just like
i was just like in such disbelief that i
was like that can just happen
like you can do everything right she
died in the car on the way to the event
yeah brutal i'm glad that it was
brief though instead of suffering for
such an angel though it sounds so bad
that dog was perfect
it just kills me yeah man but it's also
like something
well yeah but also like i've never seen
like
shitty dogs live for forever
you know it's always like the best dog
humans as well i
i was gonna make it entirely true
stephen sondheim turned 91 yesterday
he's pretty good person that's the must
be shitty
if you're over 90. you must suck you're
an [ __ ]
yes next time you see someone's over a
hundred happy birthday gertrude
you know speaking of speaking up
uh here here's something here's
something that i
i know i told i think i told troy this
but i don't think i said it here
so you guys have private conversations
okay this is i thought we were
contractually obligated to bring all our
nonsense to this show
that's true all right so yeah disregard
that betty white
not that long ago turned 99 and i saw
a striking fact that i had never
um uh that just puts things in a weird
perspective
betty white is older oh yeah than
anne frank if she were alive
wow that doesn't that strike you as
somehow very counter-intuitive and
astonishing
counter-intuitive but well it just
seemed it just
we have a tendency to just sort of
compartmentalize and it's
especially anybody associated with the
mammoth's an egyptians thing right what
do you mean
as though under 30 year olds coexisted
on the podcast i would like to
still walk in the world when egyptians
ariana grande and cardi b
are the same age that may not mean
anything to
anything to betty white and anne frank i
i prefaced it with the millennial
comment
is she 22 how old is she i think it
might be my ariana grande
is 30.
she's older than me 49. 27.
but she's so lonely also 27. 27 but i
was born in august she was born in june
and she has this song that just came out
where she talks about
having sex until the daylight and i was
like you can't be doing that you're 15.
what are you doing oh god i never
understood that she was like girl i love
you so much and i'm only nine years old
i'm like no no you don't you don't know
my heart is breaking over you girl cause
i'm 13.
hey i just smoked my first cigarette
out by the way i'm sick no
we were having a great conversation
there that i derailed with my six
cody having sex wait a minute
mike bithell you my mammoths and
egyptians
walked the earth at the same time i
think that's true i'm gonna quit it's
like bible [ __ ] right there that's true
dinosaurs and man
because you of course as well the fact
that like greeks and romans were
contemporaries and we think of them as
one after the other
there's lots of stories after another i
think it's more like
the height the height of the ancient
greece
the hellenistic age the hellenistic age
uh uh ended and that's why uh man unless
somebody's
still accepted existed during the uh the
very
coexisted with the pyramids the pyramids
were built after before the mammoths
died out
i was in well some of them i said no
i was in athens at a museum and
there was like this huge timeline it was
talking about all the different ages
and it was the when the romans came
when the roman empire started to emerge
they looked back to the greeks
maybe you're right maybe there was just
like this small overlapper it was brief
it's it is brief yeah there was a i
think i'm just looking up now
i would imagine a few hundred years troy
being like but i went to a museum in
athens that can't possibly be right
but romans but romans are also just
super interesting in terms of
like like my favorite fact about the
romans is the romans don't know when the
roman empire started yeah nor were they
called romans
that's that's like or no no sorry it was
the greeks the greeks weren't called
greeks
there was a completely different name
for them and there's so much about them
that we don't know
and that's why the romans were so
compelled to learn about them one of the
reasons why they're so compelled
like the romans look back and go these
guys had it right
it's the same thing we do now we look
back on uh those are the good old days
remember we should just go back and it's
like the arrow has always been pointing
in this direction
like it's never been austin you've said
this before
we i someone's going to get a dollar
from me saying this by and large
this is the best time to be alive right
now oh
far and away i get very annoyed by
people are too sensitive these days i'm
sure i've said this before too
when we used to try to outlaw types of
music
they were killing people in the streets
for being gay
okay are we too sensitive now um that
that was so extreme
they still are killing people in the
streets for being gay people who are gay
are still treated
terribly and that this is still
happening but i felt the need to say
that
that is fair yes that's a yeah yeah
that's a wonderful thing to bring up
there's still there's still places in
this
the simple vectors considered satanic
and you were cancelled if you were
reading a a horror novel
like it's you know we've come away
i grew up believing
that if you even looked
at a ouija board or even thought about
playing dungeons and dragons
that you might as well just be given the
engraved invitation to the devil to come
to exist in your heart
like there are definitely a lot of
possibilities right there are lots of
people who feel the same way still
though right
about dnd i don't know i wonder how much
of this is just moving away from those
communities
i think the internet i never got that
like i that would have been perfect for
me this
this kid that was wild imagination
didn't
really like to go outside wanted to play
and was creating characters and worlds
and voices and all this stuff
if i could have someone said here's a
20-sided die
go create and sit down with your friends
and learn like when i watch stranger
things i was like that's what it was i
mean
obviously critical role had started
doing this but i didn't realize i was
like you guys are playing dungeons and
dragons are you just like doing
exorcisms too
and all this [ __ ] like seances and i had
no idea i had no idea
i was the uncoolest nerd
growing up i didn't know related
i think that you should at some point do
a a
d charity stream what if we dedicated a
saturday to play in d and d and raise
the money for some kind of challenge i
would love that
i feel like i would we'd have a great
steal one shot who do you want to dm
that's a good question do you want a dm
or do we get outside dm
i feel like we get a super experienced
outside dm for that
i think i mean i don't think there's one
that we can think of
let's see if we can let's see if we can
get the almighty
what's the charity my son well jesus
we're thinking that maybe
you know there's been a lot of people
that have taken a position
on
like i censored myself
here
that would have been funny there's all
sorts of places i could have gone with
that
that was for you audio listeners that
was a little radio play
jesus was not actually it was riveting
you made some you made some very very
strong choices in your performances
this is my third couple might be in five
minutes i'm gonna make us talk about
video games
uh i have a i have a video game related
comment that's just a one okay
i interrupted mid-set
up to a the concept of a concert well
because i i wanted to bring this up last
week
and it slipped my mind and i will go
nuts if i don't bring it up
okay i think this is a first respawn
is i'm feeling i'm feeling very
antagonized
um i like that i'm the victim uh
reese you're definitely the victim yeah
yeah um
i'm feeling respawn
i have these giant eyes on my screen
just just just hostility
uh respawn is i believe the first
ever oscar-nominated video game
studio because in the new medal of honor
they included
um they included uh some documentary
shorts
about actual um
like uh veterans and i think there were
i think there were stories about
holocaust survivors and the latest medal
of honor that does a return to
wow you're right from medal of honor
wow dude yeah a short film from what
about metal honors in the documentary
short category at the oscars and i think
that's the f and so like
vince and whomever at the top of respawn
are oscar-nominated executive producers
now
i don't think that's ever happened
before i thought that was actually
really cool
if i may i ever every opportunity i get
i like to point out the fact that
vince is a really really good dude
he messaged me out of his way he asked
me if i wanted this batman figure that
he had and i never followed up and now
i'm like
you should give me you should do that he
i think i think i think an oscar
congratulations reply
no no no no no no no
side note by the way you still got that
man what's up
office address and i'll have my
assistant send it over i didn't reply
i'm sorry vince we were doing something
for keely
and um he said hey man um
i just want to make sure that we're cool
like out of nowhere i was like
what he's like i just i understand there
was like some um
there was something that maybe you
didn't want to work with us
and i went i don't know what you're
talking about but i want to clear this
up right now i said that's not true i
said i hold you in the highest regard i
love what your studio does i love that
you're like the rock star
punk of of the industry like i love what
you did
really loved that train sequence on jedi
fall in order
i love that now the the fact that like
he was look
he he was just first of all you created
or you you iterated upon and opened the
door for a whole new genre
um with what medal of honor did and then
you go forward and and everything you
did with call of duty
um the studio that he created infinity
war we could talk about as far as
whether they function well or not but
he is a dude is just that he didn't have
to do that he was just like i just want
to make sure that we're cool and there
have been some weird miscommunication
that some in between interloper had put
a
poison in his ear about me and i was
like dude i never said that happens all
the time i'm really glad to hear that
all the time high school stuff in our
industry is ridiculous the number of
like rumors
kind of circle back to you it's like
jeez really okay
and then to follow it up this was the
button on the story
he was they um they were doing like
the big launch for um
uh sorry the the titanfall was coming
out
and he said um uh
they're doing a thing in in paris
they're doing the thing in london i was
like are you flying over he goes
no man i just want to stay home uh i
want to be at the studio when when we
when we launch and i was like you don't
want to go to paris because
i really just rather be with my team i'm
like
you're a good dude man sully
sullenberger
that's who he was just personally my
team would understand
i just you know it'd be cool exactly
exactly you were about to raise a topic
about the contemporary games industry
that you wanted to talk about yes please
thank you
but first i do want to ask something
[Laughter]
uh okay so you got this tweet that i
have shared with you all of us you have
seen it
um this one is from john buck who i work
with he's lead gameplay programmer at
santa monica studio
uh and it is about an article that i'm
showing on screen are you a games writer
uh might be
cannot confirm or deny um that
is a screenshot of an article from a
website the headline is ubisoft court
rescanning assassin's creed valhalla
armor sets
uh ubisoft new free more dramatic
yule armor set included the godly reward
is a lazy reskin of existing huntsman
armor
uh john's tweet says the word court
irritated me here all games do this if
they do not do this games would take a
lot more time to make and would be more
expensive to buy
imagine if every tree or every npc or
enemy had to be
a unique also the content in question is
free not post release content
so i've seen uh devs all over my
timeline all week talking about this
with the exact same stance
um but you know naturally i've not seen
people on youtube cover it
because the youtube rhetoric is
generally no it's lazy screw game
developers unfortunately um that's a
broad stroke but that's just
that's the
and they have to invent an entire new
music theory and everything it's
incredible yeah
yeah totally so i kind of just wanted to
bring it up to uh give any of you a
chance to speak on it
um as i feel like that yeah like i said
the stuff on youtube has been covering
the
the lazy aspect where my twitter
timeline where people maybe don't follow
developers
is entirely this is how video games work
so uh mike
why is this how video games work are you
lazy
so are you lazy one of my favorite hot
takes i saw on this
uh was genuinely from a game developer
going you know what sometimes we are
lazy
and so are you at work and i liked that
i thought that was like fair enough yeah
we're all
yeah sometimes it's like i don't even
use control c when i want to
uh move information over you got to
retype it there's
there's a few things one is everything
in games takes time and money to make so
therefore of course you will get reuse
out of stuff
two uh what i've not seen people comment
on is but it's true is that like
we have limitations in terms of memory
and in terms of disk size in terms of
various metrics where
we can't make all of the infinite
content without reusing stuff
if you loaded up an assassin's creed
level and every character had a
different outfit on
it would take hours and it would
probably burn your console to the ground
right
so there is there's actually technical
reasons why you can't
load too many assets in at one time uh
so
it's yeah it's it's just the nature of
making stuff but what yeah the
the frustration i think that devs felt
with that one is because it's okay like
in
always it's always okay for the audience
to not understand how games are made
that's our job that's fine
when it's an accusation or it's framed
as an accusation we've been
caught doing something or we're being
lazy that's when devs kind of you know
react negatively to it because it's just
do you think there's obviously no do you
think just to just to play devil's
advocate for a moment because obviously
everything you're saying is true
let's just say for a moment i've bought
like a dlc pack that's like new armor
new skins new such and such like games
offer routinely
and then i feel like i'm buying a thing
that is actually intrinsically identical
to something that i bought
and it really is just the most baseline
aesthetic difference or something
do you think that i have reason to be a
little bit like i don't know that i'm
getting my money's worth
if i just think it's been missile to you
yeah i think if you if if the thumbnail
was the wrong image on the store
or if a game developer has gone on the
record saying this is all 100
brand new unique content sure but if you
buy two t-shirts in a store that
are the same you know same brand in
different colors then
yeah you've got two t-shirts that are
slaying you know because there's a
factory process to production
but no i think if it been i don't know
in this specific case i've not seen the
details
if this if this has been miss sold
that's a different sorry apologies it
was a free asset
oh and which case yeah very difficult to
steal me on that one
yeah exactly the devil's advocate has
just unfortunately resigned
yeah but then you gave me for free yeah
right okay which case yeah it's just
it's it's a shame because the problem i
the frustration i think for a lot of
devs especially devs who are actually
like
with the utmost respect to the executive
team who and which i guess i'm one as a
studio owner
like the people who actually are kind of
doing the work on the dev side
the frustration is is not even
necessarily this specific criticism or a
specific criticism
it is the antagonistic relationship
you're describing alana it's the
knowledge that a large portion of the
audience
assumes we're acting against them most
developers
are you know just trying to entertain
you and earn their salary
um and that's and that's the frustration
is when you see an audience
you know rightly criticizing business
practice but
when it's criticizing the developers
that's that's that that frustrates i
think in a lot of cases but
it seems like the opposite you could be
now if you go the other way you're like
we created a unique asset for everything
like well now you're being frivolous
look how much you had to create why not
just re we obviously had to wait you
know
it took more time and and our budget
would had to increase because we had to
do this because we know that this is
what the consumer care is about
i was like well why don't you just reuse
that stuff so you don't have to charge
me as much it's like
you can't win so you shouldn't have
done that many of this because i didn't
like this part of the game that happens
all the time too
it was like right let's see well
criticism's fine to be clear like i
think i think it's okay for the audience
to like feel like a developer like
like to look at a game and go i think
this game was too focused on this area
i think where it gets frustrating is
when ill intent is assumed
every developer has tried to do the best
job they can under whatever constraints
they're working under
and yeah there are lazy devs because
there's lazy people in any job
but they're not the norm because if they
were games would not release games are
really hard to make we do see a lot of
accumulations
like ill will and bad faith are
developers are accused of that kind of
thing a lot like being anti-player
and like you fundamentally pay their
salary they're not anti-you they're
like there are some fans that become so
indignant about such seemingly
trivial things that i can see they're
developing this like
you know damned if you do damned if you
don't attitude towards the player base
especially if it's like a long-running
franchise with a
kind of an established but by and large
yeah i find it odd to think ah you said
by and large
catching on i feel my hair becoming
i started um a buddy of mine
big martial arts dude and and i said i i
really want to be nine feet tall
nine feet tall it's very big dude and i
said i want to
i want to learn he was like come you
know come train with me so i started to
hide you on the head
yeah um
i started training with him and so i
started for the first time in my life
[Laughter]
learning how to like you know block and
punch and
and i hope this story has nothing to do
with what we were talking about
this is an absolute sea change i really
do his mind has just been wandering this
whole time i just i want this to be just
um oh so
i i started seeing like you know i
started working on these patterns he's
like i want you to think about what's on
the inside what's on the outside because
that's how you know are you blocking to
the outside are you going to the inside
and so i started seeing all these
patterns and i found myself behaving
differently like i remember being at a
bar
and somebody bumped into me and i was
like
dude you know what i can do i can grab
your arm here and then i can
you know i started thinking about how i
would quote beat this
guy up and so i i started becoming
very a little bit more i would skew
towards aggressiveness
and i would become more arrogant in
those situations
and it's because i understood a little
bit of how to fight
and stunning krueger in action isn't it
yeah so i literally there was one time
where this guy
came in front of me he yelled at me and
i got out of my car and i was like what
and i told my buddy about this and he
was like you've learned nothing
he was like a fighter someone who really
understands what a fight is
would not even get out of his car and so
i think there's a lot of people that
understand
a little bit about how games are made
and a little bit about
what it takes to create something and a
little bit about this
and so they feel that there's this level
of entitlement to be able to criticize
it
but typically what i see from those
people is
the tendency to be a little bit more
aggressive of course the tendency to be
versus the people that have actually
done like you i've shipped a game and
now their level of empathy is
far far greater because they've they've
gone through the process and
the true fighter is the one who goes i
don't care
but i do think i do think there's a
maturity that we should we should hope
for in the audience and to be clear i
don't
actually blame the audience generally i
think this is largely the people
speaking to the audience and
speaking the poise in the first place
it's not about like genuinely
we need the audience to criticize us we
need the audience to hold our games
accountable and tell us what they hate
and love
and all that that's all really good i
think the problem is when
uh presumption of intent is jumped to if
um if
if that article had in the article in
question had just said
hey this new rpac is crap and it's just
it's just
a reskin of something that already
exists you would not have seen that go
around game dev twitter
it was those specific words the late
yeah we were all just triggered by it
yeah exactly presumption of intent is
very that that to me is a hallmark of
someone
anybody uses inflammatory language that
way is not
speaking the truth or speaking
subjective opinion yeah and well
i i think as feedback is oh sorry i'm
just gonna say like i agree with you
that
you know the number one thing that i've
learned in the near six months that i've
been at a studio now is how much i don't
know
god it's been six months but that's that
my number one thing is the amount that i
do not know and i've been in the games
industry for me
i've visited 30 studios i've interviewed
probably 100 developers like i've seen
games in progress probably more than a
lot of people who even work in triple a
have by virtue of being in media and
there's so much that i don't know
on the the flip side of that though i
don't think that consumers or
players should be expected to know i
agree that them in signing
assigning a negative intent is terrible
but the idea that it's like well you
just don't know what you're talking
about
regarding just baseline criticism i
don't think it's fair because it's not
their jobs to know
that that is not what they said to play
our games and enjoy them
yeah well they don't have it how about
this they don't even have a job
right it's it's that you're all
unemployed
it's the notion that as long as the
feedback is actionable
it's like i didn't like it tell me why
no i i i
i disagree with you on that i think it
doesn't need to be actionable yeah i
just tell me you hate my stuff that's
absolutely fine and god knows a lot of
people do but like
but what can you do with that if
somebody says i hate your game what can
you do on the individual level not a lot
in the aggregate that's where the
benefit and
so that this is where like being a
developer so you know take something
like solitaire conspiracy
now available in steam it's a terrible
game
we get obviously we have all the steam
reviews that's really useful as a metric
and people should leave positive reviews
it's awesome it boosts up visibility but
those who don't
leave negative reviews and sometimes
those are just as [ __ ]
but sometimes they are actually kind of
these are things we could work on and
have and tweak
but the other thing is like every time i
don't think people know this like
if you if you get a refund on a game on
a store
the developer gets sent the text you
typed in when asked why
like and i can and it's it's a joke
among devs is like if you ever want the
most depressing evening you can have
you can jump on the back end and look at
the hundreds
of essentially like they're like text
messages because they're so short of
text messages explaining why someone
refunded one of your games
and they're just typically short or
typically long typically short because
people are in a hurry they just play the
game they didn't like so they want to
get their money back and go which is
absolutely fair enough but my point is i
don't know
and it feels like a hotel like people
who leave like a bad review it was like
to begin my experience was and it's like
this [ __ ]
but i do i do think it's useful like i
do think there's value
in that and even if they're even when
they're wrong that's what play testing
is can we do an episode where you read
some of those folks
through my twitter
i made them oh god i i made a rule a
long time ago that i'd stop reading it i
have fortunately i have a big enough
team now that other people read those
lists
i have people read that aggregated
together because no one's just
emotionally like if you're a developer
who worked on something for ages and put
your heart and soul into it
you don't want to sit and read hundreds
of people who dislike your game
can be too much but some of that is
actionable feedback listening at a
company level i think that people should
be allowed to say you know
dislike things i don't agree with the
let people like things like
twitter rhetoric of like don't let
people say they don't like things i'm
like no if someone dislikes something no
matter who works on it they should be
allowed to say that
i think it's when it the assigning of
blame the attacks is when things get out
of hand
and um i think that we've also seen
something like that like
consumption of intent right that's the
thing that infuriates me across the
board like and always has that that
annoys me more than almost anything else
um
but i think we have also seen some
developers who've been overly hostile in
response to any kind of criticism and
that's created this like
this pretty messy relationship across
the board where it's like media
devs and players in some cases can feel
like they all don't like each other
um which you know what we should do we
should start we should start
some kind of podcast where developers
kind of speak
in a way that humanizes them yeah you're
the only dev realistic people
i was gonna say i think
can i jump on that because that that
i've seen that comment a few times on
this
because troy being the only person i
think these two are i think everyone in
this podcast is a death we're all devs
everyone on this team is on this call is
a dev but the the the i've seen that
comment a few times on the i
try not to read the comments to be
honest but like i've seen that comment
come up oh i love reading the comments
we have saturday morning that that we
have great comments
let me finish please let me finish my
thing troy because this is important
like because it's compliments of you as
well
by all means please continue
there is definitely like the or there is
there is weird gatekeeping on the part
of players often that they want to
diminish kind of
the role like the deviness being just
because i'm the only person on this call
as far as i know who can
code doesn't mean i'm the only dev
developers are
everyone who's worked on game there's i
would say if you're if you're working
if your work is basically resulting in a
video game you're a developer that's the
definition
among most developers i know in the
games industry where it's where
where i've noticed it's different isn't
specifically in like the web development
community
their developer means specifically
someone who's writing web mode
but in games industry like if you're an
artist if you're a composer
if you're an actor if you're a writer
whatever you are even if you're not
writing code
you're a dev and if you think about
games in their current context
of course they do require a lot of nerds
like me who write the code
but actually there's many more people
working on gaming i'd go one step
further
i'd actually if you look at the earliest
generation of games
where you know like 30 30 plus years ago
where teams were really small and it was
basically all programmers and therefore
games tended to have
you know programmer art and programmer
music
and and you're no longer a dev i've
decided
on this sentence like demoting the whole
the whole
like the whole first generation of
composers were basically just
who here on the team knows anything
about music because they're all they're
all basically programmers and engineers
to varying degrees
and and someone happens to also be like
a side hustle
you know musician and say oh you know i
can do the i can do the score
and so interestingly the proliferation
or i should say the
the um the the massive
sort of exponential rise in the quality
of games
seems to correlate or not not to
diminish the early games of course
there's many classics which i hold near
and dear but
the ability to do things fundamentally
impossible
to those early games in a way was
contingent on people coming in who are
like nope
i can't code but i can do phenomenal
backgrounds
and as an artist adjusting this skill
set like that's
that that's the thing i remember my
first design manager
i asked him how he decided as a designer
he said i was the only artist
i
we'll finish this conversation and then
i also have to go
so all i'm saying was like there's an
interesting thing in the games industry
which has happened kind of on a loop for
almost every discipline which is
no one cares about a thing then people
realize they have to do a thing and
someone on the team mucks in so that
design manager i said i
i was mentioning he told me the reason
he got a design job was he put his hand
up when
someone asked the art team who could
make a level like that was that was that
was the generation before mine
then you see but you see it on an offset
so composers is an interesting one
because composers yes
real real composers came into the games
industry quite early
game designers we're looking at kind of
the in the 90s that became a job that
was seriously considered a real job
writing's actually one of the more
recent places if you look at me
uh and most uh kind of people in charge
of writing teams
were not writers they were something
else and they kind of migrated where
they got their job in the games industry
some other way
and then migrated into it and it's
relatively recently that people like
yourself alarm are being hired
specifically to be a writer from day one
and we're seeing that in triple well
widely undervalued
so many studios don't even don't even
like i think i would be very careful
about the studios i would work for
because it would be
tough to work for one that didn't value
writing i think i would have a really
tough time
sure yeah and and writers are often
called in it seems
at least from my perspective writers
seem to often show up
as like this oh [ __ ] we've been working
for three years and we haven't
had anything to say yeah like can
someone come in and just punch this up
and work within this
it's like it's like can you design the
layout of this house but by the way
we've already put up all the two by
fours and the drywall and
like but we really need we really need
you to figure out how to how the
sort of layout is gonna work stories are
only gonna get better and it's going to
be exciting to watch but
to the to the earlier point of like what
is a developer
um i feel like anyone like like mike
said anyone who makes a game is a
developer and i don't know that i
well i don't want to disagree with it
you need a marketing team to make a game
they are still required to ship a video
game that's you need a community team
to make a game like all of those people
are required for the they're often
throwing in ideas right
yeah all the time the community
manager's gonna be throwing in game
design ideas they're going to be
influencing even if even if you feel
like that's a gray area like they're
still putting in
work the only place i draw a line is i
don't think game journalists are game
devs for example because they're
separate they're i also don't think like
separate marketing teams
would necessarily be devs for people who
work in studio i would say like
yeah you're you're a dev and there there
is a weird i don't take this personally
although like if people would not say
that i am one like
this is another thing that offends me in
the slightest but it is a thing that i'm
like
i think broadly if you are working on a
video game existing you are
developing a video game like the
suggestion that i am not developing a
video game is like
but but that but these bits wouldn't
exist but then they wouldn't be here
so how does that work the game has to be
developed in a lot of different ways
it's not just programming
it's definitely a thing that worries me
is that it's
those are apologies i think are my
connections like the um
the thing that frustrates me the only
thing it's not it's not that i'm
insulted or i worry about your feelings
on this
i think the thing that the thing that
bothers me about the concept of like
that person's not a dev is is actually
the person watching this video and
reading the comments who's maybe a young
person
who hates programming has no interest in
programming but he's like the
best at something else and would bring
that talent to games
development and if you're if if they are
being told by their peers
in the in the comments that like this
person's not game dev then that might
devalue that for them and i
want that person in the industry what i
don't want in the industry is the person
who's saying that person's not deaf i
want the person they're putting off
from kind of getting started so that's
yeah that's selfish
more cool people making games and the
composer world has been full of that
kind of crap forever and ever you know
it was always
like if you can't like the easy the
lowest hanging fruit one you hear all
the time is if you can't read
sheet music you are fundamentally not
eligible to be labeled a composer
well the trick of course is to be you
where you don't actually need to read
any music you can just play any tune on
queue without
even looking at these paper right like i
i yeah i just yeah that
that that whole notion actually it's
funny enough that that's a perfect
demonstration of like there are people
that can just sit at an instrument and
like
divine glory bursts forth and they have
no way
they have no analytical tools to
describe what they've just done
but there can be no denial of the
brilliance of what the i mean the
ultimate example of all time is of
course paul mccartney he can't read
music
and like he's basically the best
songwriter he and john lennon
essentially of all time you know and and
the idea that
that he couldn't write down what he
himself writes
is it's just it's just gatekeeping
keeping a voice found pretty [ __ ] that
is
bit [ __ ] yeah not a fan let's lock the
gatekeepers out
yeah i was trying to i was trying to go
somewhere like that with it i was i was
trying to think like
i i really i really want to put like a
really high standard for gatekeeping to
try to minimize the number of
gatekeepers
um okay before i have to run which i do
have to do really quickly mike i just
wanted to ask you one
last question about you know this this
game devs are lazy
um you are austin uh but the
i was asking on your behalf but thank
you you are yes i feel special
i am also i'm fine with it uh
the suggestion that uh reskin is lazy
anyway is something that i
believe is not true but i figured i
would ask you about it like how
difficult is it
um to reskin an armor set in any case is
that something that you can just copy
paste do in two minutes like how easy is
changing the way uh that looks
i know that this would be suggested so
it it's actually
it's also very big i mean the the re
let's talk specifically in triple a
because in india it's a completely
different thing because probably all
those jobs are being done by one person
in triple a it's not that it's any
easier it's just it requires less people
so in triple a if you're just doing a
new if you're just
doing new materials on a on an object
theoretically that becomes a job for you
know
a concept artist to figure it out a
texture artist to get it done
and make new materials a qa department
to check that it works or design and
maybe to do some implementation that's
probably about all you need to do it's a
few other things but that's
most of it whereas yes if you're making
a completely new armor from scratch
there's like five other steps and five
other people involved so
it's not easier for any of the
individual practitioners and developers
on the team making that happen
but it requires less people so it is
cheaper and faster because you're not
you're not going through as much process
in the indie world because all those
jobs are by one person
it would be easier for an indie because
to do it that way because that one
person
has less things to do but yeah so it's
not a five minute job it requires
a lot of expertise from the individual i
think there's also just the notion that
that
if you spend your time especially on an
indie or a mid-sized team
if you if you uh are investing the time
to do labor-intensive stuff
that could there could be a kind of
faster
you know shortcut um that just lets you
spend
time on the other harder things
opportunity cost right yeah
yeah it's huge on on um if if you played
abzu
you may recall that there's these long
kelp
forest uh things where you have the you
know the kind of
uh leaves the kelp leaves along the
surface of the ocean and then they come
down like trees
which is true to life how kelp forests
look where it's almost like trees
growing from above downward
and they sway you know they had to come
up with this system with
kind of creating dynamic current in the
water and so you see them
moving and so then when giant squid came
time to do the pathless it was like oh
we want wind and we want our trees to
move so they just yanked the code
and the underlying tech designed for the
kelp in abzu to be
even though it's manifesting in a
totally different way but it's like a
normal
normalized spline on a world position
it's nice something along those lines
point is like that let them do stuff
they didn't have to reinvent the wheel
unnecessarily they were able to
essentially take something copy paste
make it
fit the environment that makes sense
shut up i realized i'm just seeing the
comments coming
efficient at giants
that's the comment that's the comment
you've been demoted exactly no
i i thought that stuff was so cool
though like i said i think that's
efficient that's not lazy
but that is really cool um but i have to
run
um because i am a dev and i have to go
make a video game
you've got very devi responsibilities
deving yes i have devi things to do
just devon around go go
dev just go dev the hell out of the rest
of this day
just gonna also address it uh congrats
to all the bafta winners we've we
recorded this before the baptist so we
don't actually know who won
but maybe you saw us who knows
cool can we can we do like an overdub uh
you know thursday night like hey
congratulations to you
yeah exactly
all right bye everyone love it